Jetzt haben wir's geschafft, endlich Teil des Teams, sie spielen uns regelmässig bei Stefan und Florentin.
Das haben wir allein gepackt, wir sind nur noch zu zweit, bei Caveman, Cobra, Cripple-Lex war einst noch wer dabei ihr könntet ihn aus Folge hundert vierundsechzig kennen ansonsten von den Rocket Beams als Art Director Ben Oh, wir traten doch so oft zusammen im Motterzentrum auf,
rauchten gemeinsam Zigaretten hinterm Roddedendron-Stroh.
Jetzt nehmen wir zu zweit verdammte Podcast-Intros auf, für seine Karriere hat sich Rocketband verkauft. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Folge von Das Podcast-Uvo. Mein Name ist Stefatize und wenn sie gerade... Achso, du stellst dich selber vor. Gut. Und du bist der... Nont will, hallo, schön, ja, sind wir doch beide wieder zusammen da. Wir sind wieder zurückgekehrt, wir haben eine kleine Pause gemacht, aber jetzt sind wir wieder in alter Frische da, verstärkt und erholt. Ja, erholt. Braun gebrannt und erholt sind wir wieder da. Ein verspätterter Urlaub, ich habe drei Wochen Urlaub hinter mir und ich habe das ein bisschen genutzt, um, Kennst du ja vielleicht, wenn man in der Schule damals war, hat man die Sommerferien oft genutzt, um neuen Style anzunehmen, sich anzueignen. Immer einen Lutscher zum Beispiel, immer einen Lutscher haben. Genau, und das kannst du nicht einfach von jetzt auf gleich machen in der Schule, weil dann bist du das Gespött. Nicht unbedingt, weil das schlecht aussieht, sondern weil du was anders machst. Jetzt kannst du aber, und das glaube ich, weil du es anders machst, zum einen, weil die Leute das sofort erkennen, zum anderen, weil du es noch nicht selbstbewusst trägst. Du hast es noch nicht zu deinem selbst gemacht. Das Beste an sechs Wochen Sommerferien ist, du kannst anfangen, Cappies zu tragen, und am ersten Tag des neuen Schuljahres trägst du die Käppi, als hättest du sie nie nicht getragen.
Du hast schon Vorsprung und es ist mir auch direkt aufgefallen, als ich ins Zimmer gekommen bin,
Stefan trägt eine locker zwei Kilo schwere Goldkette um den Hals und es fällt nicht auf, es fühlt sich nicht an wie ein Fremdkörper.
Ich habe die gekauft, direkt dann am ersten Tag meines Urlaubs und trage sie seitdem.
Ich habe massiv Rückgeschmerzen, weil die so schwer ist und mein Körper nach vorne umkippen lässt, förmlich jedes Mal. Du musst auch konstant mit den Armen rudern. Also wenn du dich bewegst, dann geht's, weil dann kannst du dich von der Kraft ziehen lassen. Genau, ist ja auch die Trägheit der Masse. Wenn man dann erst mal im Lauf ist, also im Schritttempo ist, dann geht's so. Dann spielt man ja auch keine Masse mehr. Aber wenn du stehst, musst du immer rudern, als würdest du auf so einer Slackline stehen. Manchmal trage ich die nicht und dann käme ich immer hinten über, weil das Gegengewicht dann fehlt. Ja, musst du nach vorne rudern, wie eine Ente. Ja, aber da denkt man ja nicht dran. Ja, man denkt immer nicht dran. Bist du beim Schreien, war eine gewisse Erholung zu spüren, findest du nicht? Ja, das war eine sehr entspannte. Ja, da denkt man gar nicht dran. Ja, hallo, Entschuldigung, das ist ist meine Brieftasche. Ja, lass ihn laufen. Entschuldigung, das ist mein Auto. Schatz, wir haben Urlaub. Schatz, wir haben Urlaub. Auch ein guter Satz. Er hat sich im Auto geirrt, der kommt schon wieder. Genau, dieses Ehepaar, wo einer schon auf 180 ist, sobald der Palma der Mallorca betritt und immer den Gegenpart, der immer noch so sich einredet, ich hab Urlaub, der aber irgendwann turnt, wenn der andere dann erholt ist. Und so stecken sich immer beide an mit so einer Anti-Haltung. Es gibt ja zwei Arten von Urlaub, die ich klapp den Laptop zu Urlaub und die ich schalte den Laptop aus Urlaub. Welcher war's? Ich bin jetzt noch, das sind die beiden, das kann ich mir aussuchen. Aber du bist ... Das ist die Wahl, die ich treffen muss.
Du bist der Laptop.
Was?
Wurdest du nur zugeklappt?
Ja, ja, ich wurde nur zugeklappt.
Oder wurdest du ausgeschaltet mit dem Turn-Off-Knopf?
Nee, ich bin im Ruhezustand Standby, aber noch aufgeklappt sogar.
Ach so.
Echt gesagt.
Okay, gut. So einer war's.
Ich bin kurz Bildschirmhelligkeit runtergemacht. Der bin ich.
So zwei Drücker. Ich bin Volume aus meinetwegen, aber Bildschirmhelligkeit zwei runter. So war ich. Ich war weit aufgeklappt. Zumindest auf die Seite gelegt, den Laptop? Also zur Seite, dass er sich auch mal entspannt kann? Nein, ich stand mitten im Raum, stand ich weit aufgeklappt. Sitzst ein Laptop oder steht ein Laptop? Oder liegt ein Laptop. Oder liegt ein Laptop. Und wenn man ihn zuklappt, dann liegt er. Dann liegt er. Hat sich schlafen gelegt. Also er sitzt, normalerweise sitzt ein Laptop. Auf deinem Schoss. Ja. Das ist weird. Er starrt dich an. Gegen dein Consent sitzt er auf deinem Schoss und starrt dich mit seinem Riesenauge an. Ja. Ich finde lustig, ich finde geil, ich finde Fernseher so sympathisch, weil sie dich angucken mit diesem Riesenauge. Nur bereit, dich zu entertainen. Nur für dich. Alles, woraus ein Fernseher besteht, ist auf dich gerichtet. Ich finde diese Aufmerksamkeit, die einem Fernseher gibt, total irre. Was ich gerade sagen wollte, ist, mein Style, den ich mir angeeignet habe, ich habe mir jetzt einen schicken Mantel gekauft. Nicht den, den du hier siehst. Das ist mein alter, aufgetragener, 18 Jahre alter Mantel. Nein, einen neuen Mantel habe ich mir gekauft, weil ich dachte, den muss man auch tragen lernen. So, habe ich am Anfang des Urlaubs gekauft und habe den jetzt mittlerweile tragen gelernt und ich glaube, es fällt nicht mehr auf, dass ich diesen Mantel neu habe. Nee. freut mich. Und das Problem ist nur, ich habe den gekauft und habe mir so eine große Tüte gegeben, so eine große Papiertüte, habe den dann reingemacht, war leider mit dem Fahrrad in der Stadt allerdings und bin dann mit dem Fahrrad zurückgefahren. Ja, und ich wusste, oder war das passiert, als ich die letzte Folge aufgenommen habe? Ja, stimmt. Du bist hingefallen, du bist gestört. Ja, das war das. Du bist hingeschlagen. Dann weisst du es ja schon. Ich weiss es schon. Ich dachte, das ist dir noch mal passiert. Nein, das ist mir noch mal passiert. Wenn jemand mir die Geschichte zweimal erzählt, dann denke ich nicht, oh, der erzählt mir die Geschichte nochmal, sondern ich denke mir, was dem ist genau dasselbe noch mal passiert? Nein, gut, dass wir es jetzt schon merken und nicht erst danach oder in den Kommentarspeite. Aber ja, das ist nachhaltig ein Problem und mein kleiner Finger
ist noch nicht wieder genesen. Aber du
bist natürlich dann schon sehr dumm,
weil du nimmst dir eine der
sorry, nee, du nimmst dir eine der
schönsten Freuden des Jahres,
wenn du dir einen neuen Mantel kaufst,
weil die schönste Freude des Jahres ist für mich
erster Tag Mantel
an, was ist denn in den Taschen?
Eine kleine Zeitreise, ein kleines Geschenk von Florentin von letztem Winter. Ja, wow, tolle Geschenke. Was ist da drin? Ja, kann ich dir sagen. Eine Packung Taschentücher. Ja, aber die habe ich vergessen. Zerfledder, wo schon das erste, was noch raus lugt. Ja, aber die habe ich vergessen. Oh, Kopfhörer, Kabel, Kopfhörerkabel. 3000 Euro in, nee, 3000 Dollar. In 5-Dollar-Münzen? In meiner Brusttasche? Kommt die denn? Oh, was ist das hier oben? Ein Ticket für einen Kinofilm. Was für ein Kinofilm? Star Wars. Hab ich gesehen im Winter. Im Winter 1977.. Im Winter 1977. Ja, das ist für mich die schönste... Was ist das? Eine Goldkette, wo noch das Etikett dran ist und das Preisschild? Hm, komisch. Was ist das denn? Ein Handtuch mit Blutflecken? Oh, hm, komisch, was da wohl los war. Wahrscheinlich hätte ich Nasenbluten. Ein Messer? Ha! Was? Oh, Chlorofo- Schlägt hin. Aber das ist für mich der schönste Moment, mich selber zu überraschen, weil den ersten Tag Mantel kannst du entscheiden, den letzten Tag Mantel kannst du nicht entscheiden. Du kannst nie sagen, heute ist der letzte Tag Mantel. Jetzt deponiere ich die M&Ms für nächstes Jahr. Sondern so, du weißt nie, wann das letzte Mal ist. Wie Jesus nicht wissen kann, dass es das letzte Abendmahl ist. Genau, der geht in jedes Abendmahl und sagt, Leute, heute wird richtig gemalt, aber sowas von, Freunde. Wer hat Bock auf Wein? Wer hat Bock auf Wein? Spezi, Spezi, Sprite, Spezi, Cola, kein Wein. Na gut, fuck. Kann der auch, das steht in der Bibel, ich weiß nicht, ob es in der Bibel steht, die hat ja oft auch so einen zweiten Teil, glaube ich, könnte er auch Sprite zu Wein machen? Cola verwandeln. Kann er Mezzo mixen? Also wenn, eine Frage an den Papst, eure Heiligkeit, wenn Jesus Sprite zu Wein macht, ist der dann auch mit Kohlensäure? Nee, Frage, ohne scheiß Frage. Also Jesus kann Wasser zu Wein, nee, doch, Wasser zu Wein machen, ne? Ja. Ja? Ja, ja. Er kann Wasser, klar, kann Wasser zu Wein machen. Wenn er Sprite zu Wein macht, schmeckt die dann auch zitronig. Schmeckt der Wein dann auch zitronig, weil, also er kann ja das Wasser, kann ja auch einen Menschen, so einem Weinmenschen, wir bestehen ja zu großem Teilen das Wasser, kann er Menschen töten, wäre er der weirdeste Avenger aller Zeiten, wenn er einfach Menschen töten kann, indem man die Teile Wasser in uns zu weinen. Als Mortal Kombat Charakter, finish him und dann einfach so wird zu Wein und dann so eine schöne Weingurke. Und dann werden deine Augen so rot, bestimmt ekliger Tod. Ja, aber man schmeckt gut. Die letzten Momente eines Weinmenschen sind ... Oh, boah, mhm, mhm, mhm. Was ist das, Chardon-Tod? Ja, Chardon-Tod. Ja. Jetzt weiss ich nicht, ob Chardon auch eine Rotwein-Rebsorte ist. Ist doch nicht so wichtig, Stefan, du bist Mantel-Stefan. Ich sag nur. Diese Woche musst du nur Kompetenz in Manteln vorweisen können, alles andere alles andere ist egal. Ich bin auch Weinstefan jetzt, ganz, ganz toll, ich war ja im Ausland. Ich muss sagen, ich habe es doch nochmal gewagt, ich war in Zürich, habe einen guten Freund besucht und da das Beste an dem Trip war, dass mein Kumpel in Zürich hat einen zitcomartigen Freundeskreis. Ach cool. Und sowas habe ich noch nie gesehen. Der hat einen Freundeskreis, ich kenne nur Freundeskreise, wo alle in der gleichen Bubble sind. Alle sind Lehrer, alle sind Medizinstudenten, alle machen Jura, whatever, alle arbeiten irgendwas mit Medienkram. So, sein Freundeskreis besteht aus dem heißen Typen, dem Nerdy-Typen, dem Koch, wo alle immer noch abends hingehen, wenn der dem Laden gehört sogar.
Das ist das zweite Set neben der Wohnung. Das zweite Set ist die Bar. Exakt wie die Bar bei How I Made Your Mother, aber die mit den schon hochgestellten Stühlen, wo alle nach der Arbeit zusammenkommen, weil er den Laden schon abgeschlossen hat und so weiter. In der Küche ist noch irgendwie so eine Küchenhilfe, die gerade noch spült. Und er bringt noch so die letzten Reste, die übergeblieben sind oder so ein Kuchen, was übergeblieben ist und so. Und er hat noch so einen verrückten Grossvater, der im Dachboden lebt oder so? Natürlich, ja, natürlich. Der laut immer, weil es so laut war, gegengerufen, an dem man auch nie sieht, aber der von einer sehr bekannten Stimme gesprochen wird. Ja. Jetzt bei uns im Deutschen war es die Synchronstimme von Kevin Spacey.
Ja, gut, ja.
Freut mich, dass er noch Arbeit findet. Ja, genau.
Er hat ja nichts falsch gemacht.
Nee, die Stimme hat nichts falsch gemacht.
Überhaupt nichts falsch.
Oder wem wem wem wem wem wem jetzt.
Man wem wem wem wem jetzt.
Die Stimme.
Die Stimme, ja, die Stimme.
Ja.
Aber er hat auch keinen Job mehr.
Und ich dachte auch kurz, was wenn wir jetzt nach drei Wochen wieder anfangen, wir haben eine Woche noch ausgesetzt, aber wenn wir nach einer Woche wieder anfangen und du bist so ein Corona-Leugner oder so. Ja, stark verändert. Ich habe heute zum ersten Mal seit langer Zeit Katjana Gerz wieder gesehen, habe mich sehr gefreut. Und bei dir ist ja eine Tick eine Zeitbombe, da weiß man auch nicht. Und da habe ich auch gedacht, ich war so kurz, ich habe, meine erste Frage war, und, Corona existiert schon, oder? Ja. War keine schöne, eine gute Icebreaker-Frage. Ja, ja. Aber ich dachte, just checking the vibes. Ich wusste nicht genau, weil wir haben uns so lange nicht gesehen. Katjana ist ein sehr impulsiver Mensch, ein bauchiger Mensch. So, da kann es immer mal sein, dass sie an die falschen Leute gerät. Absolut. Es ist ganz wichtig, immer abzuklopfen, einfach zu sagen, Mondlandung ja oder nein, was ist genau am 11. September passiert, einfach kurz abzuklopfen, einfach damit man weiß, wo man ist.
Voll. Und dann hat sie auch gesagt, ja, sie glaubt daran und ist auch für die meisten Massnahmen dagegen, etc. Also keine Angst, Florentin, sie ist noch auf der richtigen Seite.
Aber auf dem Weg zu dem Ort, wo wir uns gesehen haben, ist sie in ein Taxi gestiegen und der Taxifahrer war ein Corona-Leugner und she just went with it. Sie hat einfach, sie hat eine Meinung aufgegriffen und ehrlich gesagt, ich kann es total nachvollziehen. Ich finde es super nachvollziehbar. Ich bin auch so konfliktscheue, wir hatten es in der letzten Woche, vorletzte Woche über konfliktscheue Menschen, ich kann es super nachvollziehen, lieber die Meinung anzunehmen von jemandem, anstatt jetzt da irgendwie groß den zu bekehren oder zu erklären, warum. Ja, das bringt eh nichts. Aber bei Verschwörungstheorien, ich fände es auch lustig, wenn jemand aus meinem Kreis an eine Verschwörungstheorie glauben würde, aber an eine von diesen Egal-Verschwörungstheorien. Es gibt ja die ganze Bandbreite von Holocaust-Leugnung zu Impfungen, wo man wirklich sagt, Leute, das richtet Schaden an. Aber dann gibt es halt auch so Verschwörungstheorien, wie habe ich letztens erfahren. Die sind süß. Es gibt eine Verschwörungstheorie, dass der Grand Canyon aus Papier ist. Ja. Und das ist so, hey, wusstest du, dass der Grand Canyon eigentlich aus Papier ist? Ich würde einfach so, just go with it. Einfach, ich wär da sofort dabei. Ich glaub, da will ich jemanden aktiv unterstützen
für die Verschwörungstheorie.
Einfach, weil du sagst, es ist halt egal,
dann ist der halt aus Papier, mein Gott.
Ja, das find ich auch okay, ehrlich gesagt.
Sowas find ich total, weil, ja, das riecht keinen Schaden an,
das ist irgendwie süss, jemand glaubt trotzdem,
dass er irgendwie zu der elitären Gruppe gehört,
die die Welt durchschaut haben.
Ja.
Aber ich find's auch gut, weil, also jetzt gerade Impfgegner und so, die können schon immer wieder aufs Thema kommen. Gespräche landen oft organisch bei dem Thema. Genau. Problem bei den Grand Canyon Leuten ist, das Gespräch nicht organisch bei den Grand Canyon Leuten. Und das nervt dann, glaube ich, wenn es jemand befreut ist. Die haben ein absolut unfassbar großes Wissen zum Thema Papier, Papierstein, warum sieht der aus wie ein Stein. Und immer wenn das Wort Papier oder Grand Canyon fällt, trinken die gerade im Büro und pusten sie immer aus. Selbst am Nebentisch, wenn sie sich bei der Party für den falschen Gesprächskreis entschieden haben und im Gesprächskreis halt nur Scooby-Doo, alte 90er-Serien und sie denken sich, ja, komm, komm. Und dann hören sie im anderen Gesprächskreis, wie man sagt, ja, Grand Canyon sieht ja schon ein bisschen selbstmütdig aus. Ja, ja, ja, okay, ich muss, los, schnell, was, ach so, ihr seid schon wieder ein Jaguar-Fan, ja, scheiße. Die sind übrigens aus Pappe. Ja, genau. Es gibt auch eine Verschwörungstheorie, dass alles nur halb so groß ist. Oh, oh. Also, dass wenn du sagst, wow, Amerika, Globus, so und so viel Quadratkilometer ist Amerika gross,
es gibt die Verschwörungstheorie, dass es eigentlich nur halb so gross ist. Aber alles? Alles, jedes Land. Aber dann ist es ja wieder genauso gross. Ja, aber es ist halt einfach ... Aber wie weit geht diese Theorie? Ist der Mond auch nur halb so gross? Ja, es ist alles nur halb so gross. Ja, hä? Und das Universum? Ja, genau, es ist alles, es ist, die, die, die Skalierung ist schon gleich, aber es ist alles, also alles ab einem gewissen, ab, sag ich mal, ab einer Größe von Ländern oder so. Also das Auto ist jetzt schon so und so viel Meter lang. Und er hat das gerechnet, und zwar ist er so eine Straße entlang gefahren und hat dann geguckt, wie lang die angeblich ist oder so und hat dann ausgerechnet, wie wie lange er gebraucht hat, und das ausgerechnet und hatte halt einen Zehnerfehler drin, einen Fehler, hat sich einfach verrechnet. Aber das hat er so weit getrieben, dass er dazu gekommen ist, dass einfach alles nur halb so groß ist. Das liebe ich ja an der Flat-Earth-Dokumentation. Das ist so niedlich. Ja, aber es gibt diese tolle Flat-Earth-Dokumentation auf Netflix. Kurze Spoilerwarnung, weil das jetzt, werde ich jetzt spoilern, sonst spult doch einfach ein bisschen vor, wo sie am Ende, wo die die ganze Zeit dabei sind, das zu beweisen. Die kaufen dann diesen Gläser und so. Und ich finde es total schön, weil das ist ja Wissenschaft, also an etwas zu glauben, was man noch nicht beweisen kann und dann einfach zu überlegen, wie kriegen wir das falsche, wie es oder verifiziert.
Und ich finde es total cool, wenn eine Gruppe ganz so an etwas glaubt und dann aber auch, und so finde ich Verschwörungstheoretiker, Forscher sind ja auch Verschwörungstheoretiker, die dann aber halt so breit sind, die extra Meile zu gehen. und diese Gruppe, Flat Earther, komplett Idioten, haben wir dann angefangen, haben dann coole Leute dazugeholt irgendwie
und haben dann so einen Laser gekauft und wollten dann
wirklich eine Meil zu gehen. Und diese Gruppe, Flat Earther, komplette Idioten, haben dann angefangen, haben dann coole Leute dazugeholt irgendwie und haben dann so einen Laser gekauft und wollten dann, wirklich haben sich in die Wüste gestellt, haben diesen Laser probiert und haben geguckt, wir können beweisen, dass die Erde nicht rund ist, indem wir auf dieser Wüste diesen Laser schiessen und der müsste ja, wenn man Papier vor den Laser direkt hält, müsste er auf der gleichen Höhe sein, wie wenn man kilometerweit weg ist und dieses Papier hinhält, müsste er auf der gleichen Höhe sein, weil er ja nicht an Höhe verliert. War er nicht. Und dann Abspann. Das war total geil. Es endet quasi, wie sie feststellen, dass sie die Ernstheit nicht recht hatten mit dem Beweis, dass die Erdenkrümmung hat. Und dann denke ich mir, wie geil, dass diese Hobbygruppe jetzt einfach dieses tolle wissenschaftliche Experiment auf die Beine gestellt hat. Ja, es ist spannend, aber ich weiß nicht, ich glaube auch nicht, dass ich immun bin. Wie der Moral auch gerade, Verschwörungstheorie sind super. Ja, total. Ihr müsst halt nur da, beweist halt mal was. Ja, ich glaube auch, dass ich nicht immun bin gegen Verschwörungstheorie. Ich glaube, da kommt noch irgendwas um die Ecke oder irgendwie, wo es dann mal heißt, irgendwas sei eine Verschwörungstheorie. Weil ich weiß gar nicht, ob die denken ja nicht, dass es eine Verschwörungstheorie ist. Die denken ja, das ist halt einfach nur Underground-Wissen und sagen dann, ah, von wegen, alle sagen Verschwörungstheorie. Was sind denn die besten? Welche sind denn wahr? Top Ten? Also wie meinst du, nee, lieber die Top drei Verschwörungstheorien, die keine waren, sondern echt passiert. Also, ich würd sagen, Top-drei, alle Gummibärchenfarben schmecken gleich. Das ist halt auch schon seit einer Weile im Raum. Und es stimmt. Und es stimmt tatsächlich. Es schmecken tatsächlich alle Gummibärchenfarben gleich. Es ist dasselbe. Alles dasselbe. Nein. Doch, es ist dasselbe. Was? Aber es war lange halt nur eine Verschwörungstheorie und die wurden ausgelacht von wegen, warum sollte denn Haribo uns genügen? Ausser von der Fiesensetzung Haribo, die gesagt haben, fuck, sie haben uns rausgefahren. Scheiße, scheiße, scheiße. Ich wusste, dass dieser Tag kommt, so mitten in der Nacht wachte auf der Goldbär in seinem Bett. Nee. Wacht auf mit so einem Pager. Bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip. Und seine Frau Sie haben Frau oberkörperfrei neben ihm, Schatz, was ist los, es ist soweit, es ist soweit, nein, nicht heute, hol die Kinder, hol die Kinder, nein, aber ich habe gesagt, hol die Kinder, der Adler ist gelandet, ja genau, so der Haribo, Hans Riegel aus Bonn, der nachts rausgecallt wird, gut, dass er nicht Hans Bogel aus Riel hieß, sonst hieß es Haburiy. Harboury. Wäre aber auch okay. In jeder Parallelwelt heißt es wahrscheinlich einfach Harboury und es ist auch genauso schön. Aber könntest du vorstellen, dass irgendwann seinen Sohn übernimmt? Franz Riegel aus Bonn? Justin. Fraribo? Jabibo? Justin ist es nämlich, Jabibo ist es nämlich dann. Hans Riegel ist schon lange tot. Ja, rest in peace. Vielleicht können wir ein paar Worte J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J-J- Du machst das Leben froh und Erwachsene gleichermaßen. Das Leben ist wie eine bunt gemischte Tüte, man weiß nicht, was man zieht. Das Leben ist wie eine Tüte Colorado und manchmal hat man, man weiß nicht, in was man greift. Man weiß nicht, was man kriegt. Und man weiß nicht, ob alles nicht einfach gleich schmeckt. Alles hat ein Ende, nur die Lakritzschnecke hat zwei?
Ich meine sogar unterscheidend vier, weil du kannst dich in der Mitte auseinanderziehen.
Stimmt, die acht?
Ist eine Lakritz... Verschuldungsteorie.
Stimmt.
Neue Verschuldungsteorie.
Alles hat ein Ende, nur die Lakritzschnecke hat vier.
Das ist ein Tweet, Stefan.
Lakritzschnecke sind immer zwei Lakritzschnecken aneinandergeklebt.
Naja. Doch, die in der Mitte dieser Seite? Naja, ich weiß schon, aber jetzt ist eine Definitionsfrage. Die Sollbruchstelle. Ja, also wenn du die auseinanderknibbelst, ist es eine halbe oder ist es dann die eigentliche eine? Das ist halt die Frage. Nein! Eine ist es dann. Eine ist es dann. Eine ist es dann. Eine Schlange! Alleine halt in der Schlangenform, in Schneckenform. Die Schweiz ist so teuer, ich habe kein Geld mehr. Die Schweiz hat mich arm gemacht, das ist Wahnsinn. Meine billigste Mahlzeit in der Schweiz waren ein Thailänder, der nicht gut war, Mittagessen für 20 Euro. Unglaublich, ich kann das nach wie vor nicht, I can't process this shit. Das ist unfassbar. Das Land will einfach nicht, dass andere in es kommen, um da ... Ja, aber der Thailänder ist wahrscheinlich klug, der kauft sich thailändisches Essen in Deutschland und verkauft es dann in der Schweiz weiter. Zu Schweizer Preisen. Durch so einen Tunnel. Die haben doch so viele Tunnels, oder nicht? Die haben sehr viele Tunnels, ja. Tunnels und die sind auch, sag ich mal, bereit, es zu sprengen, diese jeweiligen Tunnels. Ich hoffe, die reagieren nicht über. Ich hoffe, die reagieren nicht über, dass einer sagt, naja, also man sagt ja, oh, beim Weltkrieg oder so sprengen die ihre Berge. Den Gotthard. Genau, aber die Frage ist halt, ich hoffe für die, dass die nicht überreagieren. Dass jemand nur so antäuscht, so und dann sprengen die den Gotthard und dann sagen die,
ich wollte gar nicht angreifen.
Ja, aber kann das nicht mal jemand machen?
Kann nicht mal irgendeine Weltmacht sein?
Ja, kann nicht mal Brasilien einfach mal alle Panzer satteln.
Alle Panzer auf ein Schiff, Brasilien, alle Panzer auf ein Schiff
und dann an der Küste der Schweiz landen und einfach mal gucken, was die machen.
Dann in diese Bergbahn rein, alle rein und dann einfach mal schauen, wie weit man kommt, bevor die alle sprengen. Ja, genau. Oder es ist nur so, die können es gar nicht sprengen. Ich glaube, die können alles sprengen. Es hieß sogar, die sind verrückt manchmal, die haben einen so einen grossen Kühlschrank. Also ein Berg ist so ein grosser Vorratskühlschrank.
Das heißt, die ganze Schweiz könnte irgendwie drei Monate lang autark überleben.
Die haben Milchvorräte, Buttervorräte, also alle Milch, Snacks, Flips, die haben Riesentüte Colorado, Muffins, so, die haben alles und zwar, und das Geile ist, das ist ein grosser, durchtunnelter Berg. Und die abgelaufenen Lebensmittel hinten werden dann immer entwendet, also die nicht mehr funktionieren, werden entwendet hinten. Entwendet? Geklaut oder was? Nee, werden genommen. Sorry. Werden genommen und verbraucht, die kommen in Umlauf, die so kurz vorm Ablaufen sind, und vorne werden wir die Haltbaren reingeschoben, damit hinten die Ältesten ans Ende andocken. Aber musst du dann alle durchdrücken? Ja, das geht doch nicht. Die haben so Riesen, so Herr-der-Ringe-artige Bergriesen, Bergtrolle. Die werden einmal alle Regale so vordrücken. Genau, alle Regale werden vorgeschoben und hinten ploppen dann die fast abgelaufenen Joghurts raus. Aber irgendjemand muss ja die Liste gemacht haben, was man da braucht. Und der muss halt echt sich überlegen. Ja, wenn ich die gemacht hätte, holy shit, die Schweiz wäre am Ende. Dinge, die ich für notwendig halte, sind nicht die, die die Menschen für notwendig halten müssen. Es ist nicht so leicht. Sagst du wirklich, wie viele Muffins brauchen wir? Was ist das Muffins-Donut-Verhältnis?
Wie viele Einwohner hat die Schweiz?
Mal 100.
So, wie viele von denen mögen Muffins? Also es ist auch die Frage, also was braucht man? Aber du willst ja auch, dass sie eine gute Zeit haben, weil ihr Lebensstandard ist ja auch, du willst ja auch erhalten einigermaßen. So, du baust schon Muffins. Also du kannst nicht nur Mehl oder so. Du musst sagen, und dann vor allem, welche Muffins? Machst du die Chocolate Double Chip, Chocolate Single Chip, Blueberry, Blueberry Streusel? Ich glaube nicht, dass Death by Chocolate die beste Sorte ist, Muffin, vielleicht, aber Kohlenhydrate sind auch ganz gut für den harten Winter dann zum Beispiel, kann ja auch kalt werden. Oder auch Eis, wie viel Calippo, wie viel Magnum, was ist das Verhältnis? Eis ist, glaube ich, nicht ... Also, nee. Kein Eis? Nee, Calippo ist nicht so Quatsch. Hä, dieses Kaktuseis, wo es oben britzelt? Kaktuseis, das finde ich gut. Weil wenn es oben britzelt, dann ist es gut auch für die Stimmung im Land. Aber es muss viele Variablen beachten. Vor allem, es würde ausschliesslich Streit geben zwischen den Einwohnern und dem Typen, der die Liste gemacht hat. Moment mal, wir haben nur die Nussschokolade? Die hatten nur die Nuss. Ich finde die gut, ich finde die lecker. Was, wir haben nur weisse Kinder Bueno? Ihr habt kein einziges normales Kinder Bueno. Nur weisse. Die weissen sind besser. Auf nein? Wieso nur die Maracuja-Jogurette? Niemand mag Maracuja-Jogurette. Warum nur die Zitronenfritt? Warum nicht die Orangenfritt? Hast du aus allen Messie-Packungen die Marzipan rausgegessen? Äh, ja, die mag doch keine, reicht doch, wenn wir die Edelherr haben. Warum hast du Schokolade am Mund? Ah, der Mann, der fummelt dann aus allen Packungen den einen raus, den er mag. Ja, das ist eine furchtbare Aufgabe, schreckliche Aufgabe. Wie, du? Wirklich, ich könnte nicht schlafen nachts, weil ich mir denke, irgendwas habe ich vergessen. Diese Waffeln, Schaum, ähm, ähm, Rührkuchen, ja, irgendjemand sagt dann, ich will einen Rührkuchen. Ich habe nicht dran gedacht. Tut mir leid.
Hätte ich an dich eingeladen.
Ich war völlig betrunken, weil du nur angemacht wirst die ganze Zeit.
Hör mich zu. Ich habe dir ja die Einperson gedacht, die war voll die Rührkuchen.
Ich muss die ganzen Moscherie essen.
Niemand mag die Moscherie, ich habe alle essen müssen.
Ich habe keine Butter gehabt, weil ich die Moscherie essen musste, weil ich auch die Moschererie gesessen geblieben bin. Bin ich nicht stolz drauf? Bin ich nicht stolz drauf?
Mit so einer grossen Flasche Robbie Bubble, die niemand wollte einfach. Und hängt er an der Decke an einem Seil und sagt, ihr habt es nicht verdient, was zu essen. Ja, und dann Noah mit seiner Arche, der die Tiere aus dem Himmel so, tell me about it, I know the fucking drill. Du hast die Zebras nicht mitgenommen? Ja, wo soll ich denn wissen, dass wir Zebras brauchen? Wir haben noch Pferde, warum braucht ihr bunte Pferde? War 17 Millionen verschiedenes Spinnen. Ja, ich dachte, wir brauchen, also hör mal auf, mich hier anzuschreien. Ich dachte gerade, parallel, wäre es nicht die beste Animated Sitcom, die Arche, die es nicht geschafft hat, die Arche aus seltsamen Tierarten. Mit Dinosauriern und Einhörnern. Ja, aber vor allem die Tierarten, die niemand kennt, weil die alle ausgestorben sind. Vielleicht auch zu Recht ausgestorben, weil es komische Tierarten sind. Aber das Patent auf, ich glaube, wenn man Patent sagt, reicht es. Archeboa. Again, wir versuchen es nochmal, Telefon, wenn ihr Bock habt, wir sind nach wie vor am Start. Gerne, Archeboa, der dumme Cousin von Arche Noah, Archeboa, wurde auch von Gott oder von irgendeinem anderen Gott, von Vishnu oder so. Dann hat parallel so, übrigens keine schlechte Idee von einem anderen Gott, das machen wir auch. Also der abgeguckt hat, der bei der Prüfung so rüber geschiebt hat. Der hinter so einer Wolke hervorguckt, während Noah seinen Auftrag gibt, so, ah scheiße. Mit seinem dritten Auge. Ja, mit dem dritten Auge. Und in fünf Rüsseln dann so, ah scheiße, da hätte ich auch drauf kommen können. Ja genau, der abgeguckt hat mit seinem dritten Auge und rübergeguckt hat, der dann auf die Idee gekommen ist, ja, mach doch mal so Arche. Und so wie Noah oder was? Nee, anders. Wie halt, nee, muss ich gar nicht das Noah. Nimm mal drei von jedem Tier. Eine animierte Sitcom über die Arche, die es nicht geschafft hat. Ja, das finde ich richtig gut.
Arbeitstitel, die Arche, die es nicht geschafft hat.
Ja, genau.
Ja, das machen wir nächstes Jahr 2021, können wir mit der Vorproduktion.
Aber halt auch viel einfach nur, weil vor allem die sind ja nirgendwo hingefahren, oder?
Also ich stelle mir das immer so vor, die Arche Noah steht auf dem Boden, da kommt wahnsinnig viel Wasser, die Archeoha steigt, steigt, steigt, dann warten die einfach vierzig Tage und dann geht das Wasser wieder weg und sie landen wieder genau da, wo sie standen. Genau in der Werft wieder klonk und dann ist alles vorbei. Das ist wie eine Zeitreise in Echtzeit. Oder haben die gesagt, nee, dann lass uns jetzt schon mal nach Westen fahren. Ja. Warum? Ja, wir haben ein Schiff, ein riesiges Schiff. Ja, aber haben wir einen Motor oder was? Ah, fuck. Ja, du kannst doch, haben wir nicht einen Segel oder was? Können wir nicht so die, können wir nicht irgendeine Tierart nehmen, als Ruder nehmen? Ja, halt so die Flunder, können wir nicht so alle schucken, so gleichzeitig? Flunder haben wir nicht, die sind im Meer. Ach, scheiße. Können wir nicht so die Hunde vorspannen oder so? Nee, die können nicht über Wasser gehen. Die sind die einzigen in der Bibel, die nicht über Wasser gehen können. Ja, dann können wir nicht den Biber hinten ein bisschen anschieben. Der Hobbyraum ist abgebrochen. Können wir nicht irgendwie so einen Wheelie machen oder so? Oder einen Donut? So einen Drift oder so? Oh, ein bisschen Wind kommt. Oh, ja, ja, ja, Drift! Ah, ja. Jetzt sind wir 100 Meter nach Westen gefahren. Gehen wir auf Sonnendeck? Ja, komm, wir gehen auf Sonnendeck. Zu den Sonnenblumen? Wir haben keine Blumen. Wir haben denn die Blumen überlebt. Welche Fritz-Sorten haben wir dabei eigentlich nochmal? Ich habe, weil ich ja weiss, was alle mögen, ich habe nur Orange mitgenommen. Was? Nein! So endet die fünfte Staffel und die Leute sagen, wow, fünf Staffeln waren vier zu viel, muss man wirklich einfach sagen. Das war einfach auserzählt nach der zweiten Folge. Ohne Scheiß, ich verstehe das, weil niemand hat doch länger Lust auf eine Serie zu schreiben oder so als drei lange Schlangen. Drei Staffeln nach 20 Minuten. Da gibt es jetzt unter den Zuhörern, mich eingeschlossen, nicht so mega viel Resonanz auf dieses Thema. Ist doch mega relatable. Geht euch das nicht auch so, dass ihr nach drei Staffeln einfach merkt, so irgendwie, mehr braucht man nicht, man braucht doch, also jetzt mal ganz Real Talk, man braucht doch nur drei Staffeln schreiben, oder? Oder der Unreadable Stand-Up-Comedian, der steht in New York im Comedy Cellar und sagt, Leute, die vierte fühlt sich doch immer so halb an. Kennt ihr das, wenn man ein Boot kauft und dann ist es viel zu gross, hä? Hä? Hallo, kennt ihr das? Mach wieder das mit den Serien! Wir sind alle Serienautoren hier zu bekommen. Ja, ha, ha, ha! Ja. Cliffhanger, Cliffhanger. Ich habe einen Kochkurs gemacht. Habe ich davon schon erzählt, wie vor meinem Sturz? Habe ich davon auch schon erzählt? Nein. Ich habe einen Kochkurs gemacht und der war wegen der fortlaufenden Pandemie sehr klein. Es war einfach nur fünf Leute und der Koch, der uns das Kochen beigebracht hat. Habe ich das nicht erzählt? Nee. Und der wollte mich ankurfen mit diesen desinteressierten kleinen Augen. Wenn ich erst dachte, es ist ein Fernkurs über Homeoffice, aber ihr wart irgendwo. Nee. Und ich dachte mir, warum nur fünf Teilnehmer, wenn die sich zuschalten können? Das sind aber viele Fragen. Wir machen es über Homeoffice, aber ihr wart irgendwo. Und ich dachte mir, warum nur fünf Teilnehmer, wenn die sich zuschalten können. Wir machen es über Homeoffice, aber nur fünf Teilnehmer. Ja, verstehe ich nicht. Das habe ich nicht verstanden. Aber gut, dass du in deinem Kopf so Fragen, Probleme baust dir gar nicht existieren. Ich steige aus, aus dem fahrenden Auto springe ich raus und rolle mich dann einfach noch so 200 Meter einfach weg. Und das war fantastisch. Und der Koch war der, war ehemals der Koch vom FC Bayer Leverkusen, heisst eine Mannschaft, die auch Champions League spielt. Und er war der Chefkoch des Teams. Und es war fantastisch, was er für Geschichten erzählt hat. Und es war auch ganz toll, weil wir halt nur fünf Teilnehmer waren, konnte der halt super Hands-on uns das Kochen beibringen. Und nebenan hast du dann immer mit dem dann die Gänge gegessen und dann wieder gekocht. Und ich war halt sehr interessiert an seinen Geschichten, weil das fantastisch war, weil er, wirklich meinte, ja dann reist du halt mit dieser Fussballmannschaft nach in die Ukraine und die haben halt super krasse Ernährungspläne, diese ganzen Sportler. Das sind ja professionelle Sportler, professionelle Athleten, die müssen speziell essen, die haben eine spezielle Ernährung, die kriegen natürlich super tolles, ausgesuchtes Essen immer und da sind keine Sachen drin, von denen die nicht wissen, wie die auf den Körper reagieren. Und dann reist er immer so eine Woche vorher in die Ukraine zum Beispiel, weil die gegen Dynamo Kiew im Viertelfinale der Champions League stehen und muss dann so scouten, wo sind die Orte, wo ich für meine Jungs einkaufen kann und so weiter. Und er meinte, das Beste an den Vereinen und der Fussball, wie er gerade ist, sind die ganzen jungen Fussballer, so die 17 Jahre alten Fussballer, die keine Wünsche haben, weil die noch nicht alt sind, die haben noch keine Gewohnheiten beim Essen. Die kannst du richtig erziehen mit deinem Essen, die kannst du so richtig herrichten, denen gibst du einfach das, was, keine Ahnung, wovon du dann sagst, ja, das müsst ihr jetzt jeden Tag essen und so, die nehmen das einfach an, weil die auch nichts kennen, weil die damit aufwachsen mit diesem Essen und er sagt, das ist total cool, wie die mittlerweile Automatismen bauen, zum Beispiel kriegen die eine Mahlzeit immer dann, wenn eine sehr intensive Trainingseinheit bevorsteht. Zum Beispiel, du kriegst eine Stunde vor einer intensiven Trainingseinheit eine Portion Milchreis. So, das machst du ein paar Mal und irgendwann weiß der Körper, wenn er Milchreis bekommt, ah, in einer Stunde muss ich extreme Leistungen abrufen. Das heißt, wenn die plötzlich mal, normalerweise spielen die immer um 15.3030 Uhr samstags, die ganzen Mannschaften, und der Körper kann sich schon darauf vorbereiten, das ist ja der Automatismus, aber wenn du jetzt dann irgendwie, damit ich in der Ukraine um 20.30 Uhr abends plötzlich Flutlichtspiel hast und gegen Dynamo Kiew krasse Leistungen abrufen musst, kriegst du eine Stunde vorher Milchreis und dein Körper weiss, ah, egal wo ich jetzt bin, es ist mir scheißgal, alle anderen Eindrücke werden vergessen, ich muss jetzt Leistung abrufen. Und dann kannst du die wirklich zu diesen krassen Leistungen auch mit Essen erziehen. Empfiehlst du das auch für weniger professionelle Leistungen, dass wenn du irgendwie, keine Ahnung, eine Klausur vor dir hast, eine Stunde vor der Klausur irgendwie dir schön Zimtmilchreis aufmachst? So, ich mache das nämlich immer jetzt. Immer bevor du lernst. Folgendes, wenn ihr lernt, während ihr lernt, snackt ihr einen bestimmten Snack. Und jetzt fangt ihr schon nach vorher an. Also, jetzt mal du einen. Ja, genau, nur ein Beispiel zu nennen, Orangenfritt. Fangt ihr an, ähm, fangt ihr an zehn Minuten Formlernen und dann immer beim Lernen immer mal wieder ein Stückchen Fritt. Ja, aber du darfst halt dann ausserhalb des Lernens nie Fritt essen, sonst machst du dir die ganze Konditionierung kaputt. Kannst du auch, wenn du da funktionieren willst. Nein, mach es mal erstmal nicht. Nee, nee, nee, bitte nicht. Noch nicht die Regel brechen, bevor wir sie überhaupt aufgestellt haben. Ja, okay. Erstmal Fritt essen, so, und dann weiss der Körper immer, ah, wenn ich jetzt dieses Wissen abrufe, dann esse ich Fritt. Heißt, wenn du Fritt isst, rufst du auch dieses Wissen ab. Konditioniert euch mit Essen. Das war die Stephan-Dieter-Masterclass.
Finde ich eine gute Idee. Ich habe wirklich jetzt gerade, musst du intensiv nachdenken, wann ich mal eine hohe Leistung abrufen muss und ich bin auf nicht viel gekommen, eigentlich auf gar nichts. Ich habe ein relativ niederschwelliges Leben, würde ich mal sagen. Wenig Hubraum. Aber du bist doch ein cleveres Kerlchen. Dann musst du doch mal das schon, ja. Ja, aber dann musst du doch dein Gehirnchen doch mal mal anstrengen. Ja. Aber du liest anspruchsvolle Bücher zum Beispiel. Naja, ab und zu mal so hinten, was da draufsteht. Du guckst sehr komplizierte Filme wie Tenet. Ja, das stimmt. War Tenet vielleicht, würdest du sagen, der anspruchsvollste Film, wo die höchste Leistung des Gehirns gefordert wurde seit den besten fünf Jahren? Ach ja, du sahst nach dem Film ein bisschen so aus. Ein Mainstream-Blockbuster, ja, ich war komplett durch. Mainstream-Blockbuster war für mich der anspruchsvollste Film. Ich meine, ich glaube, der zweitschlimmste Film ist Irreversibel von Gaspar Noé, der halt einfach komplett falsch rum erzählt ist. Also der fängt mit dem Ende an und dann geht es halt falsch rum. Aber das checkt man halt irgendwann und dann denkt man sich, wow, wie sind die da hingekommen? Ach, mit dem Bus. Wie sind die in den Bus gekommen? Ah, die haben da an der Bushaltestelle gewartet. Anders als man sonst in den Bus gekommen. Das ist einfach ein grosses Ah, weil das hätte ich nie erwartet. Da wird es doch immer anders. Aber ja, so hangelt man sich durch den Film. Wie sind die an der Bushaltestelle gewartet? So hangelt man sich durch den Film. Ach, die laufen dahin. Aha, wo kommen die her? Aus ihrer Wohnung. Aha, haben die sich die Jacke angezogen, bevor die aufgebrochen sind zur Busseite.
Es ist ein Erlebnis. Es ist spannend.
Also macht das mal am Wochenende.
Schau euch den Film an. Nein, der ist ziemlich intensiv, der Film.
Während ihr Filme schaut, die ihr gut findet,
weil dann könnt ihr,
wenn ihr mal schlechten Filmen guckt, auch
Frit essen, dann weiß euer Kopf,
ihr müsst den Film gerade gut finden.
Ja, es stimmt schon.
Ihr könnt euch mit Frit, das wollen wir ja nur sagen, euer Leben schöner machen. Ja. Ich suche momentan eine App, ich habe nämlich, als ich in Berlin gelebt habe, habe ich eine App gehabt, wo ich mein Gedächtnis trainiert habe und das war so eine ultra hardcore App, die wirklich krass war. Damals war es auch sehr anstrengend, weil du immer sehr schnell gesprochen hast und so sehr umtriebig war. Weil ich einfach im Kopf hatte, viel Gedächtnis, ich konnte auch viel zurückgreifen. Jetzt ist so... Er hat sich gerade seine Haare genommen und so dran gezogen. Jetzt ist so... Da war so... Damals war mein Gehirn wie so ein vollgepacktes Fließband an der Kasse, wo wirklich so, wo man nicht hinterherkommt, so biep, biep, biep, biep und so ganz so dreistöckig. Und die Kassiererin war so, what the fuck, jetzt war so, ich habe Portemonnaie vergessen. Und die Kassiererin musst du alles wieder hinter sich nehmen, bis du mit dem Portemonnaie gehst. Genau, jetzt ist es, oh, ich habe noch Mehl vergessen und rennt noch mal runter in unteren Stockwerk. Und dann kommt einfach ewig lang nichts auf dem Fließband. Und das ist mittlerweile anders. Aber ich finde die App nicht mehr. Ich habe schon danach gesucht, und es gibt andere Arten von dieser App, aber ich will genau diese App noch mal haben, wo man nur gleichzeitig sich Audiosachen merken muss und visuelle Sachen, und das ist ultra krass. Ich hab den Namen vergessen von der Gedächtnis, von dem Gedächtnisspiel, was es damals gab, und Scheiß von für Nintendo DS. Aber war das nicht auch ... Doktor wer war das? Doktor Kawashima. Aber das war auch ... Ja. Das war mal ein Tweet, oder nicht? Oh mein Gott, ich dachte gerade, das wäre der beste Tweet. Nee, nee, nee, ich glaube, der Tweet war, ich kann mich irgendwie nicht aufraffen, das Motivationsbuch zu kaufen. Sowas in der Ecke. Ich kann mich nicht mehr an den Namen des Doktors erinnern mit der Gedächtnis-App. Auch nicht schlecht. Naja, viel zu kompliziert. Ausser mit. Jetzt? Wie hieß nochmal dieser Gedächtnistrainer Doktor? Wie hieß nochmal dieses Gedächtnistrainer-Spiel für DS oder sowas? So, jetzt kommt die Stephan-Tie zum Masterclass. Wie formulierst du den Tweet jetzt? Ich würde dahinter noch so ein, das fand ich nämlich gut, ersetzen. Ja? Sowas wie ... Genau, wichtig ist, dass dir selber nicht auffällt, was die Ironie an deinem Satz ist. Ja, also jetzt im Spiel. In der Rolle, in die du kurz schlüpft, um deine vielen, vielen Follower zu begeistern. Falls ihr noch nicht Teil der Tietze-Welle seid, der Tietze-Lawine. Der zweiten Tietze-Welle. Wie hieß nochmal dieser Doktor Tietze-Ramonie? Das war mal ein Tweet. Ich merke, mit Tweet, dass Das war mal ein Tweet.
Ich merke, mit Tweet, dass es so mal ein Tweet war.
Ja, das ist so die Autokorrektur, schlägte den gesamten Tweet vor.
Meinten Sie das?
Meinten Sie Max Bierhalses Tweet?
Genau, von 2005.
Scheiße, das ist ein echtes Zeichen.
Nee, haus raus!
Haus raus!
Nee.
Haus raus! What a Haus raus! Haus raus!
What a character!
What a weird guy!
Haus raus!
Motivations... Aber ohne Schlecht, ich glaube, mit dem hast du ein besseres Leben.
Absolut. Haus raus!
Zum Thema
weird und lame
noch mal ganz kurzes
Feedback zum Gewinnspiel von vor zwei Wochen. Wir haben ja vor zwei Wochen ein Gewinnspiel gestartet zum Thema, wer findet meinen Skype-Namen raus? Ich will jetzt nicht übertreiben, aber das war die dummste Idee, die ich je hatte und dieses Gewinnspiel hat auf allen Ebenen nicht funktioniert. Okay. Das Gewinnspiel war von der ersten bis zur letzten Sekunde eine Katastrophe. Mit Ansage und Anlauf. Mit Ansage ins Messer gelaufen, komplett nicht funktioniert, katastrophal eine Bruchlandung, ein Reinfall, ein Schlag ins Wasser, wie ich letztens gelesen habe und es nicht verstanden habe und es googeln muss.
Schlag ins Wasser.
Finde ich gut.
Oder aufs Wasser sogar, weiß ich nicht.
Egal, auf jeden Fall, wir haben Tipps.
Es gibt einen Reinfall übrigens.
Es gibt einen Reinfall bei Schaffhausen,
Barchener Nähe, andere Geschichte.
Es gibt einen Reinfall.
Es ging darum, dass ich einen merkwürdigen Skype-Namen habe
und wir haben drei Hinweise gegeben, die den Zuschauer ermöglichen sollten, auf den Namen zu kommen. Und ja, stellt sich raus, man muss einfach nur Florentin Will bei Skype eingeben und man findet meinen Namen. Somit gab es sehr, sehr viele Gewinner, denn alle, die versucht haben, das Rätsel zu lösen, sind gescheitert. Alle Ergebnisse, die auf tatsächliche Rätselrate gekommen sind, alle falsch. Also alle Rätselrater haben verloren. Falsch, alle Betrüger gewonnen. Also alle, die Spaß hatten und ein bisschen gerätselt haben, sich hingesetzt haben mit dem Bleistift und dem Zettel, die haben alle verloren. Ja. Und die Vollidioten, die haben wir den Namen gegeben haben, wie du auch angekündigt hast, die haben alle gewonnen. Ja, ich habe sehr süße Bilder bekommen von Leuten, die zusammensassen mit Blättern Papier,
wo sie aufgemalt haben die Hinweise und sich überlegt haben, mit so einer grossen Pinnwand,
mit roten Fäden haben sie überlegt, niemand hat es gefunden, aber, und dann auch nochmal ganz kurz,
das Rätsel war ja sehr leicht, man hat ja gesagt, hey, findet meinen Skype-Namen raus,
und wenn ihr ihn rausgefunden habt, dann schreibt mir auf Skype, weil dann habt ihr ja meinen Skype-Namen,
und dann bekomme ich ja die Nachricht. Die Leute haben auf Twitter geschrieben, auf Instagram, mir Mails geschrieben, im Habo-Hotel habe ich Nachrichten bekommen, überall haben mir die Leute geschrieben, ist das dein Skype-Name? Ja, dann schreibt doch auf Skype! Das hat mich auch wahnsinnig gemacht, wie wirklich da die einfachsten Sachen nicht verstanden werden, aber viel Glück an euch und weiterhin, also viele, viele haben die richtige Lösung gefunden, wir haben auch einen Gewinner gekürt, Julian, Julian glaube ich war es, T-Shirt und Karten für eine Live-Show, falls ihr noch auf die Live-Show wolltet, meldet euch an und ruft an, ruft an, ruft an,? Nein. Die Hotline, die jetzt wird eine Nummer eingeblendet. Die ruft ihr an und dann kommt ihr schon durch. Also, herzlichen Glückwunsch an den Gewinner, aber es war halt der Erste, der die Folge gehört hat. Also, herzlichen Glückwunsch. Das ist genau, ich hatte auch mein Guinness-Buch, der Rekorde-Buch, wo drin stand, ältester Tamagotchi.
Und es war halt irgendein Mädchen, das den ersten Tamagotchi gekauft hat oder sich halt als erstes gemeldet hat bei Guinness-Buch der Rekorde, gesagt, ich habe Tamagotchi in der ersten Woche gekauft.
Du musst nicht immer der Rekorde sagen, es gibt kein anderes Guinness-Buch, das habe ich immer schon genervt.
Du, das brauchst du nicht immer sagen.
Das Guinness-Buch der Rekorde-Buch.
Wie viele Guinness-Bücher gibt es?
Gibt es nicht auch ein bisschen andere? Gibt es auch bestimmt andere? Ist von der Biersorte Guinness, ne? Es gibt Guinness? Ich glaube nicht. Ich weiß nicht. Was ist das andere Guinness-Buch? Das Guinness-Buch der flotten Sprüche, der tausend besten Witze, irgendwie sowas? Ich weiß es nicht. Auf jeden Fall habe ich das damals schon gesehen und da war die Vollbild dieses Mädchen, das sie in Tamagotchi hatte, und die sah auch nicht begeistert aus. Ich habe ihn halt in der ersten Woche geholt. Ich weiß nicht, was es ist. Ich habe es gesehen. Ich habe es meiner Schwester abgenommen, und ja, und die war halt da drin im Buch. Und da dachte ich mir da schon, ey, weiß ich nicht, muss das sein? Mein Onkel hat mich immer gewarnt vom Guinness-Buch der Rekorde-Buch, dass ich mich nicht zu sehr anstrenge, weil der meinte immer, das ist auch so Gesprächsthemen, wie Leute sich halt so Themen formulieren, das war wirklich ein Anliegen von meinem Onkel, seinem Neffen zu sagen, Junge, das Einzige, was ich dir mitgeben kann ins Leben, ist, streng dich nicht zu sehr an, um ins Guinnessuch der Rekordebuch zu kommen, weil es lohnt sich am Ende nicht.
Was ist seine Geschichte?
Weil dahinter schwingt,
ich habe seit 20 Jahren
versucht, den höchsten
Spaghetti-Turm aus Marshmallow und Spaghetti zu bauen
und es ist nicht geschafft.
Es gibt immer noch
diese Harvard-Gruppe, die besser darin ist,
erinnerst du. Ja, es gibt diesen Fall und er meinte, wenn überhaupt, wenn du unbedingt ins Guinness-Buch Unterrichtung des ZDF für die Zukunft der Zukunft der Zukunft der Zukunft der Zukunft der Zukunft der Zukunft der Zukunft der Zukunft der Zukunft der Zukunft der Zukunft. Weil er meinte, es gab jemanden, der meinte, am weitesten mit der Nase gerollte Erbse. Also Erbse liegt auf dem Boden und man rollt die mit der Nase. Und er hat halt dann einen Meter weit gerollt. Wie, einmal anrollen? Nee, nee, du kannst schon dranbleiben, halt so anstupsen halt. Einen Meter? Ja. Es ist nicht, hä? Es ist nicht viel. Das können wir jetzt brechen. Ja, das ist nicht viel, aber er hat es ins Buch geschafft, weil er war der Erste, der diesen Rekord aufgestellt hat. Darauf willst du hinaus. Und dann im nächsten Jahr. Ich bin in deine Falle, in deine clevere Rhetorikfalle gelaufen. Und dann meinte er, im nächsten Jahr war es schon irgendwie 14 Kilometer oder so. Also erbste 14 Kilometer weit mit der Nase gerollt. Und dann meinte er, der mit den vierzehn Kilometern, der musste sich wesentlich... Glaubst du, der hat ein besseres Leben? Nein. Nein. Und am Ende Plot-Twist, dein Onkel war der mit den vierzehn Kilometern. Ja, der war der mit den dreizehn Kilometern jahrelang trainiert hat. Mit den dreizehn, neun Kilometern. Und dann Wladimir Kosarev aus der Ukraine. Was? Wenn dann endlich das Buch rauskommt. Ja, also das hat er mir mitgegeben. Also ich habe wirklich, also ich weiß nicht, es gibt ja so. Aber These, dein Onkel hat keine Kinder. Hm, ja. Ja. Oh. Wie kommst du darauf? Ach so, weil du das Wissen an mich weitergeben musst, oder was? Ja, weil ich glaube, jemand, der Kinder hat, gibt an seinen Neffen nicht diese Art dezidiertes Wissen weiter. Oder er gibt halt an seine Kinder die richtig guten Tipps und die Neffen kriegen dann noch so Crap einfach. So den Neffen so, sei immer ein guter Mensch, hilf immer anderen Leuten, steh zu deinem Wort und der Neffe kriegt dann so streng nicht aufgeschrieben. Roll die Erbse weiter! Da gibt es jemanden, der hat gesagt, den meisten Menschen die Haare gewaschen, der hatte am Ende keine Fingerabdrücke mehr, weil der so vielen Menschen die Haare gewaschen hat. Ich hatte Horrorvorstellungen von diesem Monstermenschen, der so ganz glänzende, glatte, saubere Finger hatte. Ich hatte Angst als Kind vor dem. Ich wusste nicht, wo der ist. Aber das ist noch wichtig. Aber hier nochmal die Frage an Physiker. Wenn man jetzt Finger ganz doll zusammendrückt. Kann ein Mensch so stark werden, dass er seine Finger so fest aneinander drückt? Dass er seinen Fingerabdruck verändert. Das ist so, das ist mein, weil mein Daumen hat den anderen als mein Zeigefinger. Nein, hat er nicht. Das hatten wir schon. Das hatten wir schon mal. Alle Finger haben denselben Fingerabdruck. Ja, mein Gott, wir drehen Sieg den Kreis. Komm jetzt nicht auf Folge 180 Niveau hier runter. Nein, aber kann ... Da hatten wir es erst über Finger ... Kann ein Mensch so stark seine Finger trainieren, dass er sie so fest zusammendrückt, dass die Atome fusionieren, so dass man die nicht mehr auseinanderziehen kann, die Finger. Da hast du ja Elektronen und so gedönst und du kriegst sie ja zusammen, dass die so ganz schneller sind. Hatten wir auch schon, ja. Ja, 179. Ja, 179. Gute Zehner. Gute Folge, war eine reingeschränkte Folge. Gute Zeit damals. Das wäre ein Guinness-Buch der Rekorde-Buch-Eintrag, wenn du so fest das drücken könntest. Ja, das wäre ein Guinness-Bucheintrag. Aber man überlegt sich das ja echt, was man selber weitergibt an seine Kinder und auch an seine Neffen und so. Und ich habe ja zwei größere Brüder, von denen habe ich auch nur so ganz spezielle Lektionen mit auf den Weg bekommen. Also wirklich so, es gab ganz selten Momente, wo es hieß, okay, kleiner Bruder, jetzt bringe ich dir was bei fürs Leben, weil ich bin acht Jahre älter, ich weiß, wie es läuft. Und ich bringe dir was bei. Ich weiß, mit achtzehn, ich habe alles gesehen und ich kann dir, kleinem Jungen, sagen, wie es läuft. Und das Einzige, was mir mein Bruder jemals beigebracht hat, war, Text falschrum zu lesen. Also nimm ein Buch, dreh es auf den Kopf und versuch es dann zu lesen. Und das ist die Fähigkeit, die mir mein Bruder beigebracht hat. Mit der Begründung. Und wo ist er jetzt? Im Genussbuch der Rekorder, weil er am schnellsten die Bibel rückwärts gelesen hat. Aber er war auf dem Kopf, das Buch war richtig rum. So konnte er nämlich den anderen austricksen, der hatte nämlich das Buch umgedreht.
Der Australier, der ist das Buch umgedreht. Genial eigentlich. Und er meinte nämlich, naja, was ist, wenn du mal mit einer Frau essen bist, wo ich schon damals gesagt habe, als Neunjähriger, jetzt langsam, übertreiben wir nicht, okay. Was ist, wenn du mit einer Frau essen bist, aber es nur eine Karte gibt? Oh mein Gott. Als Gentleman überlässt man natürlich der Frau die Karte, aber man will sie ja selber lesen, wie viele Portionen Pommes man jetzt sich für 12,40 Euro, die man noch zusammengespart hat, leisten kann. Ja. Und dann musst du nämlich umgedreht auf dem Kopf die Karte lesen. Ja, das ist auch die einzige Situation, wo das ... Das ist die einzige Situation. Und dann am Ende bist du halt in so einem Deiner und sitzt neben der Frau und du denkst dir, fuck, Stunden umsonst. Ja, aber auch weird, neben einer Frau zu sitzen. Es ist unangenehm. Es ist seltsam. Mach das mal, geht mal mit jemandem ... Ihr könnt auch ein guter Kumpel sein oder eine gute Freundin oder so was. Geht mal mit denen in ein Restaurant und setzt euch mal nur mal aus Spaß direkt neben sie. Ja, genau, aber völlig selbstverständlich. Setzt euch mal völlig selbstverständlich neben sie. Ja. Und dann, vielleicht kriegen wir so eine Viral Challenge sogar hin, dass man das filmt, versteckt oder sowas. Oder zumindest die Tonauf, dass er die einfach unaufgefolgt und ungefragt filmt. Aber natürlich mit Abstand und geht nicht ins Restaurant und all das. Hört die Folge einfach in vier Jahren nochmal. Wir sind das Podcast-Ufo, wir sind zeitunabhängig. Wir fliegen in unserem Ufo ohne Zeit- und Politik-Kontext durch, dummher. Die Erde dreht sich unter uns und wir kriegen das gar nicht mit. Nein, aber wenn es geht, macht das mal oder nimm es mal mit Ton auf. Ich würde es gerne sammeln, wie Menschen reagieren, weil das ist so unnormal, das ist so gelernt, gegenüber voneinander zu sitzen, verstehe ich ja auch, anders ist es in Cafés, kennt man häufig so Strandpromenadencafés, die sind dann häufig, dass man als alle in eine Richtung gucken. Ja, oder Bars sowas. Genau, oder Bars, Bars, wo man auch am Tresen zusammensitzt, in eine Richtung guckt, immer unangenehm. Ich stelle mir gerade so eine Gruppe von acht Leuten vor, die essen geht und alle, und es ist so ein langer Tisch. Was war, ja das letzte Abendmahl. Ja, und alle setzten sich auf die eine Seite, ungefragt. Das letzte Abendmahl, what a weird situation. Na gut, auf der anderen Seite saß doch da Vinci und hat gemalt, oder nicht? Haben die sich für den hingestellt, das war ein Selfie, das erste Gruppenselfie. Im Grunde schon. Aber wie lange
würde es dauern, bis eine der Personen sagt,
Leute, warum sitzen wir
alle in einer Reihe?
Und dann, genau, dann kriegen die
Geld, je länger es
dauert. Die Uhr läuft,
für jede Sekunde, die die Uhr
läuft, kriegen die einen Euro, und dann,
wenn nach zwei Minuten jemand sagt, sorry, können wir uns
anders hinsetzen, oh, Abbruch, ähm, Euro und dann, wenn nach zwei Minuten jemand sagt, sorry, können wir uns anders hinsetzen, Abbruch, Guido Kanz kommt, da steht dann in der Mitte so ein großer, so eine Halbkugel, so wo Essen drunter ist, so eine Chromkugel, wo er denkt, da ist das Essen drunter, falsch, Guido Kanz ist da drunter und dann, wenn die Uhr abläuft, springt Guido Kanz aus der Halbhue und sagt, Time Out, die Sendung heißt Time Out, Time Out, ihr kriegt und dann kriegt ihr so 112 Euro oder so und dann blättert ihr das hin und dann hat er so eine grosse Brieftasche dabei und dann hat er 112 Ein-Euro-Scheine, legt er die hin und dann geht er, dann wünscht er euch einen schönen Abend und geht. Erst Werbung noch kurz. Dann kommt noch Werbung, dann geht er ungefragt. Fritt-Werbung kommt dann auch erst. Genau, er bezahlt dich in Fritz. Die Rennung ist auch gesponsert von Fritt. Fritz Timeout, heißt sie. Gesponsert von Fritt und von Fritz-Cola und von Fritz, dem-Anbieter, von Fritt, Fritz und Fritz Cola.
Die drei Firmen sponsern diese Sendung und dann kriegt jeder ein.
Und Fritz Box.
Und genau, Fritz Box, jeder kriegt eine Fritz Box, jeder kriegt ein Modem, jeder kriegt eine Packung Fritt und eine Packung Messi.
Und dann geht, und Guido kann es geht dann, und dann wird aber der restliche Abend auch noch gefilmt,
dass sie sagen, warum hast du das so früh gesagt, sonst hätten wir statt 112 180 Euro bekommen können. Aber das ist die eigentliche Sendung. Wir hatten damals diese versteckte Kameraidee, wie lange würde es dauern? Unser Elevator-Pitch ist immer, wie lange müsste Beyoncé bei ihrem eigenen Konzert singen, bis das Publikum geht, bis der Letzte gegangen ist. Und jetzt finde ich, haben wir zum ersten Mal eine geile Drehung, Geld. Denn die Person, die am Ende überbleibt, kriegt das an Geld in Minuten ausgezahlt. Nee, nicht die übrig bleibt, die erste Person, die es macht, nicht die letzte Person. Nee, weil bei dem Konzert wäre es ja, wie lange würde es dauern, bis die erste Person geht, stimmt, und die Person, genau, Wie lange würde es dauern, bis die erste Person das und das macht? Weil die Person reagiert. Und die kriegen, weil es geht ja immer darum, es ist ja lustiger, je länger es passiert, dass man den Amount an Minuten ausgezahlt bekommt. Minuten? Dann kriegst du zwei Euro. Die geht ja nicht nach zwei Minuten Musikkonzert. Also, bev würde ich mir schon ... Ja, aber du kannst nicht sagen, die erste Person geht. Ich will sagen, nach zweieinhalb Stunden gehen die ersten. Nein, bei jedem Konzert gehen schon nach zehn Minuten Leute. Weil es so lange dauert, das wäre die Begründung. Nein, weil die einen Anruf bekommen haben oder weil es denen schlecht wird oder so. Bei Beyonce-erten, da sind ja Tausende von Zuschauern, da geht natürlich nach zehn Minuten schon der erste.
Da geht man doch nicht, wenn ein Anruf kommt, weil dein Hund gestorben ist.
Bei jedem Konzert gehen nach zehn Minuten schon Leute.
Nicht bei Beyoncé.
Doch, hundertprozentig.
Habt ihr an der Tür von einem Beyoncé-Konzert gearbeitet, ruft uns an, wir blenden nur mal ein, ruft uns an und erzählt uns die Geschichte.
Erzählt uns die Geschichte, waren die Leute hier. Ich will nicht meiner Mutter und dir Podcast erklären. Wann Leute gehen. Klar, natürlich. Es gehen immer Leute. Ja. Es gehen schon Leute während der Vorband. Es verlassen das Kino schon Leute während der Werbung. Da kommt noch die Camelo-Werbung, Canetto, äh, Calippo-Werbung, und die Leute gehen.
Ja.
Genug jetzt, ich geh. Ich glaube, es gehen schon alle während der Fritt-Werbung im Kino. Das war, glaube ich, unsere andere Idee, weil es gibt diesen Gag von Family Guy, dass man immer nicht weiß, ob der Film schon anfängt oder ob das das Logo der Produktionsfirma ist. Und dass wir so ein Kino hijacken, also unsere Produktionsfirma,
It's a Westbrook Project natürlich,
kauft sich ein Kino auf einen Tag.
Und statt des Films laufen nur Produktionslogos. Aber halt stundenlang.
Und die Frage ist, wie lange wird es dauern,
bis einer aufsteht und an die Kasse geht und sagt,
haben Sie einen kompletten Schaden, wann geht der Film los?
Und das ist, glaube ich, schon nach drei Minuten der Fall. Na, nach drei Minuten Filmproduktionslogos. Aber wo gehen die Leute hin? Würden die wirklich an die Popcorn-Schalter gehen und sagen, Entschuldigung, weil es sind immer andere Logos? Ich liebe das ja. Ich war auch bei der Star Wars-Acht-Premiere damals im Kino, ... es war 3D, und diese 3D-Funktion hat nicht funktioniert.
Also lief so zwei ...
Ah ja.
Gleich nebeneinander der Text halt so hoch.
Und bei Star Wars war es am Anfang halt noch superekelig,
weil man das nicht lesen kann und so.
Also es war einfach super weird.
Und da war es halt schön zu merken, wie es kippt langsam.
Es war von, ah, irgendwas ist anders, getuschel, getuschel, getuschel,
hin zu, es wird nicht besser, Leute lachen, die ersten lachen laut, dann wird lauter gesprochen, dann kommen die ersten Rufe und dann kommt Hey, hey, dann wird der Saal so weird laut und dann dreht sich die Aufmerksamkeit von vorne hinten zu diesem Produktionsapparat, wo man ja, Projektionsapparatberkasse. Dieser Zauberkasse, wo das Licht herkommt. Da dreht sich so, alle Köpfe drehen sich langsam in die Richtung und blinzeln da so sonnenmässig rein. Irgendeiner geht zu dem Vorhang und zieht den Vorhang weg. Wo kommen die Lichter her? Wo kommt die Musik her? Wer ist hier verantwortlich? Wie funktionieren Kinos?
Und am Stuhl?
Wer spricht hier?
Und dann merkt die Projekt-, der Praktikant oben merkt das natürlich schon, der schon
unterwegs bei Tinna war oder die Hand in der Hose hatte, der merkt dann schon irgendwann,
oh, der Saal wird unruhig, etwas passiert, okay, ich stelle die 3D-Funktion an.
Ich war ja in Fleischbällchen mit Wolkisch ... Nochmal? Schau mal raus. Wir kommen rein. Ich war ja vor einigen Jahren in Wolkig mit Aussicht auf Fleischbällchen 2, 3D. Und der Film sollte eigentlich 3D sein. Ähnliche Geschichte wie bei dir, fast dieselbe. Genieß es, genieß es. Und dann war Kino voll, jeder hatte seine Brille und dann kam dieses Texting, bitte setzen Sie jetzt Ihre 3D-Brillen auf und alle setzen ihre 3D-Brillen auf und der Film war dann aber nicht in 3D. Wer war der Erste, der die 3D-Brille abgenommen hat? Der Film war normal und jeder hat es gemerkt. Weil alle haben auch diese 3D-Filmhaltung. Wo der Nacken, weißt du, was ich meine? Der offene Mund, Staunen. Aber es ist der Nacken zurück. Also so sitzen normale Menschen im Kino und so sitzen drei Leute mit 3D im Kino. Immer so das Kinn zurück, weil die Leinwand kommt so gefühlt 10 Zentimeter nach vorne. Der Nacken geht so nach hinten. Also als müssten sie ausweichen den Dingen, die darauf sie zukommen. Und irgendwann haben dann halt die Ersten angefangen, die Brillen abzunehmen, weil man gesehen hat, es ist nicht 3D. Ich habe auch irgendwann die Brille abgenommen, aber mir war es besonders wichtig, am Ende des Films noch mal zu schauen in den Saal. Und es saßen tatsächlich Leute da, die haben den gesamten Film über, die 3D-Brille aufgaben. Und fummeln auch noch so dran rum, als müssten sie den Anknopf drücken oder sowas. Das Lege ist an ihn! Ich seh das nicht, aber das wird schon seine... Das fand ich auch fantastisch. Leute, die bis zum Ende... Und da würde ich es andersrum machen, da würde ich sagen, der Letzte, der Letzte, der die Brille abnimmt.
Jetzt ist es Kromat Unpissable, Florentin.
Die Leinwand fährt nach oben und man sieht langsam eine schwarze Silhouette entstehen und dann kommt ein Scheinwerfer direkt auf die schwarze Silhouette.
Es ist Guido Kanz, der in den Publikumssaal springt und dann so, sorry, sorry, Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung, sich durchbahnt bis zu der Person, die gewonnen hat und dann sagt, Time Out! Oh mein Gott. Die Show heißt Time Out. Ja. Alle Lichter gehen an, jeder kriegt eine Fritz-Cola, wie gesagt, das muss man nicht mehr sagen. Muss man nicht mehr sagen. Das hat man verstanden, ist die vierte Staffel. Ja. Und dann sagen sie, oh, sie haben die Brille lange lange angehabt. Glück hat es immer so ein bisschen genervt. Er muss halt ewig warten immer. Sie haben es jetzt 68 Minuten angehabt. Ich stand hinter der Leinwand die gesamte Zeit. Und dafür kriegen sie jetzt 68 Euro. Das ist aber nicht so viel. Und diese Fahrzeuge, dieses Hochfahren und so, das fucking Production, diese ganze Produktion hat so viel Geld gekostet, darf er es für diesem Typen jetzt 68 Euro geben? Ich bin mal gerade, Guido kann es, der besser ist zu tun, als die ganze Zeit unten in dem ganz Kleinen irgendwo drin zu hocken. Der musste immer warten, immer irgendwo eingezwängt, oder in irgendeinem dummen Kostüm. Time-out, und dann immer so genervt, fängt er da hoch, ist so ein super genervt. Guido, Guido, jetzt! Time-out. Time-out hier. Oh, Alter, mein Rücken. Oh, Leute, jetzt erst, wirklich? Und dann beschimpft er auch immer die Leute, die gewonnen haben. Jetzt erst? Jetzt erst die Brille ab, wie viel Geld kriegst du? 60 Euro? Ja. Toll, 60 Euro, bitteschön. Glückwunsch hierimm die ganze Brief. Du gibst ihm mit dem Geldschein. Weißt du, was das Erstaunlichste war? Die Person, mit der ich im Kino war, ist nach dem Kinofilm an die Kasse gegangen und hat gesagt, der Film war nicht 3D, ich will das Geld zurück. Was ein 3D-Film kostet am Mehrwert. Genau, ich Ich will die Differenz zwischen ... Aus der Quersumme. Zwischen zwei D, ich will ein D. Ich will mein D zurück. Wie viel kostet eine Dimension? Das ist nämlich dann eine Frage, die man selten beantwortet bekommt. Ich will mein D. Was kostet, und so muss man hingehen, wenn das passiert, geht ihr zu Kass und fragt, was kostet die dritte Dimension? Die dritte Dimension hätte ich gerne ausgezahlt. Genau, dann kriegt man genau ein D ausgezahlt. Wie viel ist ein D wert? Ich weiß es nicht genau, aber ich fand es erstaunlich. Da sind wir ja wieder bei unserem Naturell Konfliktscheu, würde ich im Leben nicht machen. Doch, ich habe das gemerkt, ich bin jetzt auch so. Ja, du hast deine Persönlichkeit geändert?
Ja, ich hab die und zwar nach der Folge geändert.
Weil, aber das stimmt auch nicht, ich bin da vielleicht auch nicht so ...
Ist ja auch ein Spektrum so, ne, das ist ja auch nicht was er da weiss.
Es gibt nicht konfliktscheuer Menschen.
Ich glaub, du bist konfliktscheuer als ich.
Ja, das ist auch mal eine Show, so ein Wettbewerb, wer ist konfliktscheuer?
Das heißt, It's a Spectrum.
It's a Spectrum. It's a Spectrum.
Moderiert von Guido Khans.
Der auch mittlerweile gar keine Lust mehr hat.
Alles moderiert. Von uns, der moderiert alles.
Der kann alles machen.
Und ich hab auch jetzt so ein paar Mal,
erst mal, weil man kriegt immer so
Mails nach so Hotelaufenthalten,
wie es denn gefallen hat.
Und dann hab ich jetzt mal wirklich
eine ganz lange Liste mit Dingen geschrieben, die mir aufgefallen sind. Wow. Ja, und es war bestimmt so eine DIN A vier Seite Mail, wo ich ganz viele Punkte aufgeschrieben habe, die ich fand, die verbesserungswürdig waren. Gar nicht patzig geschrieben, weil ich dachte auch, das ist am besten, wenn man ganz nett schreibt, so was wie, mega, das hat mir super gefallen bei euch. Hier ein paar Punkte, an denen könnt ihr vielleicht arbeiten, müsst ihr auch nicht, ich weiß ja, ist ja auch gerade eine schwierige Zeit für uns alle. Ja, ist okay, alles klar. Und super, erstmal so eine super lange Entschuldigung und dann 80 Punkte. Was zur Hölle war da eigentlich los? So in dem einst einem Raum, wo sich die drum gekümmert, da stand ein Bierfleisch. Nur Erdnuss M&Ms in der Minibar, wo sind die normalen M&Ms? Ja, und dann habe ich mich da ein bisschen ausgekotzt, aber ich fand es total interessant, weil ich dachte, welche Mail würde ich ernst nehmen? Und ich nehme mal Zuschauerkritik wahnsinnig ernst von Leuten, die eine solide Grammatik haben. Oder die anfangen mit, ich bin ja normalerweise ein großer Fan von euch, aber. Und da bin ich dann immer on the edge of my seat, weil ich denke, was kommt da jetzt, oh nein, oh nein, oh nein, so. Und wohingegen Leute mit schlechter Grammatik oder in Caps oder was auch immer, da ist immer so, ja, ja, komm, das macht er mit jedem und das ist ein Hater, ein Flamer. Aber deswegen fand ich es gut, erstmal schön, man tut ihm am meisten weh, ich habe mich wirklich geärgert über dieses Hotel, man tut ihm am meisten weh, wenn man nett ist. Vielleicht kannst du mir helfen. Ich will so sein wie du. Ich will weniger konfliktscheu sein. Und zwar, du weißt, ich trinke gern Mate. Und es gibt ja verschiedene Marten. Und meine Lieblingsmate ist die Mate Mate von Thomas Henry. Die gibt es aber nicht überall. Die gibt es zum Beispiel hier hinten an der Ecke. In so manchen Spätis kann man die kaufen. Aber oft in Supermärkten nicht. Du hast keine Ahnung, wo wir sind gerade. Du hast in eine ganz andere Richtung gezeigt. Ich weiß, wo der Kiosk von hier liegt. Doch, da! Nein, da! Nee, du hast recht. Du hast ja nicht orientiert, oder? Nee, überhaupt nicht. Anderes Problem, können wir uns nächste Woche drücken. Und ich habe jetzt immer so einen Grundstock an Mate, Club Mate, Mio Mate, kaufe ich immer bei meinem Supermarkt ganz normal ein, aber manchmal denke ich mir, jetzt hätte ich noch Lust auf eine Mate Mate, so die Kirsche obendrauf, heute am Wochenende vielleicht, dann hole ich mir bei so einem Kiosk eine Mate Mate. Und dann gehe ich da rein und hole die aus dem Kühlschrank und laufe dann noch den Weg zum Schalter. Und das ist ein kleiner Kiosk und der Besitzer ist immer da.
Also ich glaube, der weiss nicht, ob der kleiner Kiosk und der Besitzer ist immer da.
Also ich glaube, der weiß nicht, ob der überhaupt Mitarbeiter hat, aber der ist halt immer da und ich kenne ihn auch mittlerweile und grüße den. Und dann stelle ich die Mate hin und dann muss der die Mate einmal so abscannen und dabei sagt der immer, ah, lecker Mate. Und ich finde das so schrecklich. Oh nein, das kannst du nicht verändern. Und ich finde das so furchtbar.
Und ich kaufe tatsächlich weniger Mate bei dem einen,
weil der jedes Mal sagt, ah, lecker Mate.
Und ich würde es, ich wäre so gern der Mensch, der zu ihm hingeht und sagt. Kauft mal, hier ist das meine andere Frage, kauft mal Fritt.
Ah, lecker, Fritt.
Oder auch?
Ich weiss es, ich habe noch nie was anderes gekauft.
Ich kaufe immer nur diese eine Mate. Ich würde ja vorstehen vor dem Laden und beobachten, was er macht. Stimmt. Seid ihr bei jedem? Ah, lecker Bier. Ah, lecker Fritz. Aber ich habe mir wirklich, weil ich gehe da eigentlich, ich mag den, ich kaufe da bei dem gerne ein, ich will den unterstützen und ich mag die Mate. Und ich würde so gern der Mensch sein, der zu ihm hingeht. Ich mag die Mate, als hätte er die selber gemacht. Naja, er hat sich dazu entschlossen, die Sortiment zu nehmen, was nicht selbstverständlich ist.
Und dafür möchte ich ihn belohnen.
Und ich wäre so gern der Mensch, der zu mir hingeht und sagt, pass auf, ich mag sie sehr gern und ich kaufe ihr gerne ein.
Aber können Sie bitte aufhören, lecker Mate zu sagen, wenn Sie es scannen?
Als du angefangen hast mit, kannst du mir bei meinem Konfliktverhalteninverhalten helfen, war ich selbstbewusst habe gesagt, ja, auf jeden Fall. Aber das ist gerade diese typische Hitch der Date-Doktor-Storyline, wo ich vor so einem harten Fall stehe, nie in meinem ganzen Leben könnte ich dir dabei helfen. Aber gibt es irgendeine Möglichkeit? Nein, wechsel den fucking Kiosk, das ist so weird as fuck.
Das ist genau wie eine Freundin von mir, kann ich jetzt nicht mehr zu ihrem Friseur gehen, weil der immer schlecht drauf war. Der wurde immer, nee, das ist ein Kumpel von mir, der war immer bei einem Friseur und der war immer schlecht drauf und es wurde nicht besser. Ja. Bis er hat gesagt, ich kann da nicht mehr hingehen. Der ist halt einfach so. Der war am Anfang super nett und dann hat er irgendwie eine Trennung hinter sich und sowas. Und dann wurde es langsam super weird, dann war er so sehr depressiv und seitdem ist er immer schlecht drauf und so kurz vorm Bein, wenn er ihm die Haare schneidet. Und jemand konnte da nicht mehr hingehen, obwohl er den so gerne mag und die Frisur noch immer mochte. Aber auch da kannst du schlecht sagen, Entschuldigung, können Sie vielleicht ein bisschen besser drauf sein, ein bisschen positiver, weniger, ein bisschen mehr, hallo. Und in Rom dachte ich mir das auch, da sind, nee, das war der Money-Stefan. Nein, nein, nein, in Rom habe ich mir letztens gedacht, also in San Francisco läuft das ja anders. Nein, in Rom war ich vor Jahren mal. So, und da habe ich damals schon gedacht, weil das kam ich aber, weil die Leute immer in die Restaurants winken. Da wollte ich noch einmal sagen, ihr hättet mehr, zumindest deutsche Kunden, wenn ihr die nicht reinwinkt, weil Deutsche sind dann immer so, nein, nee. Alles an mir sagt, ich will da jetzt nicht weniger rein als in den Laden, weil ich habe das Gefühl, ihr habt das nötig. Ich liebe einen Laden, wo schon niemand sitzt, wo niemand winkt, da gehe ich rein. Ich erinnere mich noch gut an die Zeit, als ich übergewichtig war. Und jetzt mal einen kleinen Shoutout an alle schweren Jungs und Mädchen da draußen, denen es vielleicht ähnlich geht. Oder vielleicht nimmt man es auch nur mehr wahr, wenn man sich seines Körpers bewusst ist oder da irgendwie vielleicht ein bisschen unzufrieden ist. Nämlich, wenn man an einer Eisdiele vorbeiläuft und der Eisverkäufer zwinkert einem so zu. Du willst noch Eis. Ich habe das Gefühl, ich weiß nicht, ob die das nur bei dickeren Leuten machen oder bei allen, aber seit ich nicht mehr überrichtig bin, habe ich das nicht mehr das Gefühl. Vielleicht ist es, wie gesagt, auch nur einfach Selbstreflexion, aber teilweise wollte ich ein Eis und in dem Moment, in dem er so diesen Blick gemacht hat, ich sage, nee, ich erfülle jetzt nicht deine Erwartungshaltung, dass der Dicke jetzt auch noch unbedingt ein Eis haben will. Und da habe ich teilweise auf Eis verzichtet, weil der diesen, du willst doch Eis haben, weil ich einfach mit meinem Stolz gekränkt war. Und deswegen denke ich mir auch da, kann man, wie kann man, also für Leute vielleicht auch mit dem Einzelhandel arbeiten, wie kann man sowas machen, kann man mit euch reden, weil ich denke mir, der macht ja das mit der Leckermate, wahrscheinlich auch nur, um die unangenehme Stille zu erbrücken, wenn er das abscannen muss, wahrscheinlich ist dem das unangenehm, das einfach so zu nehmen und zu piepen und kurz diesen Moment, das man guckt halt nur hin, macht nichts und deswegen sagt er, ah, Leckermate, ich kann das nicht hören, ich will das nicht hören. Ist mir schon so unangenehm, oh Gott, ist es mir so unangenehm, das zu hören. Ist furchtbar. Vielleicht hört, ich hoffe, er hört den Podcast. Du bist super, ich kaufe da gerne ein, aber hör auf, einfach auch das zu sagen. Kommentier nicht, was Leute einkaufen, das ist das Letzte, was Kunden wollen, ist zu kommentiert bekommen, was sie einkaufen. Will niemand, niemand. Oder sag du mal Leckermate. Gib ihm das und sag, weil er wird es, ich verspreche dir, er wird es dann nicht sagen. Die Konversation wird nicht sein, Leckermate, Leckermate. Das wird die Konversation, nie im Leben wird das die Konversation sein. Du kannst proaktiv sein Und man bringt es selber einfacher über die Lippen. Aber dann sage ich es so, dass wir es gleichzeitig sagen. Stell dir das vor, dass das würde ihn kränken. Aber ich kenne den Rhythmus. Leckermate. Das hat sich mir so eingebrannt, wenn ich wollte, könnte ich es gleichzeitig mit ihm sagen. Stell dir das mal vor. So, bitteschön. Leckermate. Bitte? Bitte was? Es ist so ein bisschen so ... Der Fluch ist gebrochen. Ja, es ist ein bisschen Groundhog Day. Ja. Oder nicht? Ich mach das. Weil du kannst irgendwann mitsprechen einfach. Ich mach das. Ich sag gleichzeitig ... Aber was ist das Schlimmste, was
passieren könnte, dass er sagt,
also dass er bis sie wirklich gekänzt wird, also hören Sie mal.
Also was
fällt Ihnen ein?
Sie können ja auch sagen, was ich sage.
Nee, ich glaube, der wird,
ich finde das fantastisch.
Das ist die beste Art, um ihm mit
auf den Weg zu geben, das sagst
du immer. Ich weiss,
du sagst es so häufig, dass ich weiss,
weil er vergisst ja,
Aber dann Das ist die beste Art, um ihm mit auf den Weg zu geben. Das sagst du immer. Ich weiss, du sagst es so häufig, dass ich weiss, weil er vergisst ja, pass auf, weil er ist ja, er hat ja vergessen, dass er das immer sagt. Wenn er wüsste, dass du immer derjenige bist, bei dem er Leckermate sagt, er hätte das ja schon lange nicht mehr gemacht. Du willst ja nicht redundant sein, auf Leute wirken. Ja, ja, klar. Das heißt, er hat so viele Kunden, dass er vergisst, wer du bist und vergisst, dass er so ein One-Trick-Pony ist. Ja, dass er ein One-Hit-Wonder ist. Er ist ein One-Hit-Wonder ist. Und in dem Moment, wo du sagst, lecker Mate, denkt der entweder, oh, das ist mein Seelenverwandter und vielleicht tausche ich Nummern aus oder sowas, oder, was auch lustig wäre, oder er merkt, ah, fuck, das sag ich immer bei ihm, das tut mir leid und er lässt es ab dem Moment, was du willst. Hausaufgabe für mich, zwei Sachen, erstens, ich kaufe eine Fritz-Cola und schaue, ob er sagt, lecker Fritz-Cola. Das ist das Erste, weil das kannst du nicht mehr verifizieren. Ja genau, das stimmt, wenn ich ihn gebrochen habe, wenn er ein Haufen Elend ist und sein Zauber gebrochen wurde. Und jetzt kannst du diese beiden Tricks machen. Ich mache beide Hausaufgaben, ich kaufe eine Fritz-Cola und ich versuche, gleichzeitig mit ihm Leckermate zu sagen. Und dann schauen wir mal, ob es funktioniert. Finde ich mehr gut. Ich fände es sehr gut. Den kann ich da nie wieder einkaufen. Aber ich bin nie kurz davor, da nicht mehr einen zu kaufen, weil es so unangenehm ist. Ja, ja, ja. Lose-loose, also ... Ich war in ... als ich in Zürich war, hat plötzlich mich ein Mann gesehen und ich bin am Fahrrad am Bahnhof vorbeigefahren, war sehr belebt, viele Leute und der hat mich gesehen und hat mich ganz nett gegrüsst. So als wäre ich a long lost friend. Hat mich gegrüsst, hey! Und ich hab das, weil ich auf dem Fahrrad war, war ich sehr schnell dran vorbei und ich habe super lange darüber nachgedacht, wer war das, wer hat mich jetzt erkannt, so schnell erkannt, hä, habe überlegt, oder war es vielleicht ein Podcast-Sufo-Hörer, der mich da erkannt hat, aber der würde vielleicht nicht so grüssen, keine Ahnung, kennt man mich dann überhaupt im Gesicht, weiß ich nicht. und dann habe ich mit Leuten darüber gesprochen, weil ich dachte auch irgendwie ja, oder war es einer von den Freunden meines Kumpels,
den ich da besucht habe, habe ich den schon mal irgendwo gesehen, kenne ich den vielleicht selber, weil so wirkte das ein bisschen.
Das war so ein, ich hätte es wissen müssen, wer es ist, Kai.
Und dann kam ich immer aus meinem Hotel raus und der gleiche Mensch kommt wieder vorbei und grüsst mich wieder so nett.
Und ich dachte mir, ich habe mich auch genitzt, dann habe ich das erste Mal, weil ich auch zu Fuß war, war ich genauso schnell, habe auch nett gegrüßt, hi, und war so kurz davor zu fragen, ja, woher kennen wir uns? In dem Moment geht er weiter und grüsst den nächsten Menschen genauso freundlich wie mich. Ah, okay. Crazy guy. Wow. Stell dich raus, ist ein verrückter Mensch, der einfach jeden Menschen grüßt.
Oder hinter dir war auch ein Podcaster und er ist Hörer von
beiden Podcasts und findet beide gut.
Er hat nur beide gut gefunden. Ich mag beide.
Du, man muss nicht immer sagen, einer ist besser.
Er hat Tommy Schmidt gegrüßt und mich
Tommy Schmidt, Donny O'Sullivan,
Olli Schulz, alle in einer Reihe
im Zürich-Til. Und danach guckt er in die Kamera und sagt,
ich bin Podcast-Fan.
Fuck you, ich bin Podcast-Fan. Und du kannst es auch sein, auf der Podcast-Plattform, die so ähnlich funktioniert wie YouTube, so dass du auch andere Folgen vorgeschlagen bekommst. So eine gute Idee, oder? Geh doch mal vorbei. Auf www.podcastplattform.net.smorg. Ich habe den Domain in der Hinterhand für ein gutes Podcast-Projekt, aber die will ich jetzt echt nicht sagen, weil sonst nehmen wir die Leute weg. Machen wir ein Rätsel? Nein, wir machen keine Rätsel. Vergesst nicht Names, Names, Names, Names. Names, Names, Names hat sich jemand gemeldet, der Bock hat, eine heiße Website draus zu machen. Ich habe ihm gesagt, machen wir, seitdem hat er sich nie mehr gemeldet. Ich habe noch einen Namen gebraucht für mein Kind. Bin auch auf Names, Names, Names, Names, Names. Names.com gegangen und es war noch, hier stand irgendwas, wo diese Internetpräsenz ist. Die Internetpräsenz ist im Aufbau, ist sie nicht. Ehrlich gesagt, das Wort Internetpräsenz habe ich noch niemals auf einer fertigen Website gelesen. Genau. Ja, so macht Google das auch. Alle Seiten, die Internetpräsenz haben, werden einfach nicht gelistet. Aber bleibt dran, unsere Projekte brauchen immer so zwei Jahre, um zu reifen. Aber ansonsten wünsche ich euch eine fantastische Woche. Wir sehen uns nächste Woche wieder, es geht weiter direkt.
Ansonsten haut rein, wir sehen uns bis dann, wir sehen uns ab, macht's gut, ciao! Bis dann, macht's gut, ciao!
It's a worst bird production.